it's a terrible loss my my father said
to me
um on the telephone um a few months ago
that
we're all in the same boat and we must
always remember that
but occasionally we in the family are
asked to stand up
and show compassion and leadership
and unfortunately with my father's death
it has brought
at home to me not just our loss but
actually the loss that everybody else
has
felt for so many people who've um
died and lost loved ones during the
pandemic
um and so we are all in the same boat
slightly different circumstances because
he didn't die from
kobe we are all feeling a great sense of
loss
but at the same time the tributes have
been absolutely
amazing that that i've seen and the
messages that i'm getting are absolutely
outstanding
um and i just want to say how grateful
uh i am we are um for these tributes
um he was a remarkable man um
i loved him as a father he was so
um calm
if you had a problem he would think
about it
and that's the that's the great thing
that i always think about is that he was
always somebody you could go to and he
would always listen
so it's great loss
i think the way i would put it is that
we've lost almost the grandfather of the
nation
and i feel very sorry um and supportive
of my mother who's
feeling it i think probably more than
everybody else
you did have the chance to see your
mother yesterday and of course
everyone's thoughts are
very much with her how is your mother
the queen at the moment
the queen as you would expect is
incredibly stoic
person and
she described his passing as a miracle
and um and she's um
contemplating i think is the way that i
would put it there she described it as
as having left a huge void um in her
life
um but we um the family the ones that
that are closer are rallying around to
make sure that that
we're there um to support her and
um and i know that that that there is a
huge amount of support
not just for her but but for everybody
um as we go through this um enormous
change um but thank you very much indeed
for for coming to
see us this morning at our private
chapel uh
where we've been able to as it were give
our prayers
um and um head on for the
for the next few days before the funeral
it's uh it's been a bit of a
bit of a shock however much one tries to
prepare oneself
for something like this it's still it's
still a dreadful shock and
we're so trying to come to terms with
that and it's
very very sad but i have to say that the
extraordinary tributes
and the memories that everybody has had
and been willing to share has been so
fantastic and it just goes to show he
he might have been our father
grandfather father-in-law but
but he meant so much to so many other
people and and just being here this
morning with
everybody from from windsor great park
and he was a ranger here for
more years than i think any other ranger
and
you know it means so much to so many
people here and it's the same for
those who lived and worked at balmoral
and sandringham you know he's
you know for all those past and present
you know means a huge huge amount
very personal they all have their own
personal memories and stories where
hearts
[Music]
always exchanged words with everybody
because it didn't matter what anybody
was doing
in and around the estate here and
everywhere else they all meant
a lot to him and he always took a very
personal interest in everything that
they were doing
so they all have got stories to tell and
most of them quite funny as well
oh yes yes so uh well because he went
carriage driving around here on
a regular basis and and but he go to
places that you know were quite
you know all over the place and uh so
we're just talking about
killed out of a few ditches here i seem
to remember as well oh well in the early
days yes
you have a few problems more recently
too
between yesterday
thinking of others before herself
as always yes um
but uh but but but burying up but again
you know it's just that that
that wave of affection for him and just
those lovely stories they just mean so
much
and and you know the tributes have been
just fantastic
and that's really really important and
we really do appreciate it so
and i think it's so lovely for so many
people to learn
about what he did because i think it's
actually quite a lot of things that have
come out um will have surprised some
people
and how intrinsic he was to every
element of society if you look at it
and it's just lovely to i mean we've
i've heard things that i
didn't even know as well but um so for
many people they'll have been learning a
lot about him
which i think is important yes
thank you so much indeed and to the
wider family and to
and to so many other countries you know
where he's well-remembered so it's just
that that outbreak from all over the
world
very much appreciated so thank you thank
you so much